all right so when I talk about making
products users love what I mean
specifically is like how do we make
things that has a passionate user base
that our users are unconditionally
wanting it to be successful both on the
products that we build but also the
companies behind them we're going to go
over tons of information try not to take
too many notes mostly just try to listen
I'll post a link to the slides on my
Twitter account and on that link there
will be a ways for you to annotate the
slides and you can ask me questions and
so if we don't get to them I'll answer
them after the talk so you guys have
been listening to and hearing a lot
about growth over the last several weeks
and to me I feel like growth is usually
fairly simple it's the interaction
between two sort of concepts of
variables conversion rate and churn
right and the gap between those two
things pretty much indicate how fast
you're going to grow and most people
especially business type people tend to
look at this interaction in terms of a
very calculated and a mathematical sort
of way and today I sort of want to talk
about these things at a more human scale
right because that startup when you're
interacting with your users you have a
fairly intimate interaction that you
have in the early stages and so I think
there's a different way of looking at
this stuff in terms of how we build our
products and we'll look at a lot of
different examples of that and how its
executed well my philosophy behind a lot
of things that I teach startups is the
best way to get to sort of a billion
dollars is to focus on the values that
help you get that first dollar to
acquire that first user you sort of get
that right everything else will sort of
take care of itself the sort of face
thing so I came to be a partner YC by
way of being alumni I went to the
program in winter of 2006 so it's the
second ever program and I built a
product called busuu booth is an online
form builder help you create contact
forms and online surveys and simple
payment forms it's basically a database
app that looks like it's designed by
Fisher Price what's interesting though
is that because it was fairly easy to
use we had customers from every industry
market and vertical
you can think of including a majority of
the fortune 500 companies out there ran
the company for five years and they were
required by surly monkey in 2013 and at
the time we're very interesting
acquisition we were only a team of ten
people at the time and while we acquired
funding out here in Silicon Valley
through Y Combinator we actually ran the
company from Florida we had no office
everyone worked from home and we're
interesting outlier so each dot here
represents a start-up that was that
exited through IPO or acquisition and
we're this outlier to the left the
bottom is the funding that they took and
the vertical axis is the valuation of
the company at the time to sum it up the
average startup raises about 25 million
dollars and their returns of their
investors about six hundred and seventy
six percent wufu raised about one
hundred and eighteen thousand dollars
total and a return to our investors
about twenty nine thousand percent so a
lot of people were very interested in
sort of like what makes we feel a little
bit different or why how do we run the
company very differently a lot of it was
focused on product we weren't interested
in building software that I guess that
just people wanted to use right that
reminded you that you've worked in the
cubicle because it was a database app at
it's sort of core we wanted a product
that people wanted to love that people
wanted to have a relationship with and
we were actually very fanatical about
how we approached this idea at the point
where it's almost sort of sort of
sightsee sort of way so what we said was
like okay what's interesting about
startups in terms of us one is a great
things that people love is that love and
unconditional sort of feelings are
things that are difficult for us to do
in sort of real life and it startups we
have to do it sort of at scale so we
decided to do is start off by just
looking at like okay how does real
relationship work work in the real world
and how can we apply them to sort of how
we run our business and sort of build
our product that way so we'll go over
basically these two metaphors acquiring
new users as if we're trying to date
them and existing users this is a
successful marriage so it comes to
dating
a lot of the stuff that we uncovered how
to do with first impressions all of you
often talk about your relationships in
terms of the origins stories actually
tell me about the first kiss how you
sort of met how you proposed these are
the things that we say over and over and
over again they're basically the
word-of-mouth stories of our
relationships and they're the same kinds
of things that we do with companies
human beings our relationship
manufacturing creases we cannot help but
create and answer for horrifies the
things we interact with over and over
again so whether it's the cars we drive
the clothes we wear the tools and
software as we use we eventually
describe characteristics to it a
personality and we expect to behave a
certain way and that's how we sort of
interact with it now first impressions
are important for the starting of any
relationship because it's the one we
tell over and over again right and
there's something special about how we
regard that origin story I'll give an
example if you're on a first date with
somebody and you're having a nice dinner
and you catch them picking their nose
you are probably not going to have
another date with them right but if
you're married to someone for about 20
to 30 years and you catch them on the
barking large you're digging for gold
right you don't immediately call your
lawyer right and then say like we have a
problem here and you start drawing up
papers for divorce you shrug your
shoulders and say at least he has a
heart of gold so something about first
time interactions means that the
threshold is so much lower in terms of
pass/fail so in software and for most
product and Internet software that we
use like first impressions are pretty
obvious and the things that you see a
lot of companies sort of pay attention
to in terms of what they send their
marketing people to work on my argument
for people who are very good at product
is they discover so many other first
moments and they make those something
memorable right the very first email you
ever get from Lisa software what happens
when you first log in the links to
advertising the very first time you
interact with customer support all of
those are opportunities to seduce so how
do we think about sort of like making
first moments on there and we actually
took this content from the Japanese they
actually have two words
for how to describe things when you're
finished with them in terms of saying
like is this a quality item and the two
words of quality are how to make an Shih
Tzu and medio Kentucky inches and the
first one means taken-for-granted
quality basically functionality and the
last one sort of means enchanting
quality right take for example a pen
write something highs media koteki right
if the weight of the pen the way the ink
flows out of it the way is viewed by the
people reading the handwriting from the
pen is pleasurable both to the user of
the pen and the people whose wouldn't
experience byproducts of it alright
taking it to the sort of next level
start with some example so this is
refused a login link and it has a
dinosaur on it which i think is awesome
but um if you hover over it the spec has
the added benefit of having a tooltip
that doesn't sing it like Hana logging
and what it does but basically bar and
what we notice about this like in early
usability studies like this put a smile
on people's faces like hands down right
universally and I think a lot of times
when we are assessing products never
think about like hey what is the motion
on the person's face when interact with
this this is vim use login page this is
actually a couple iterations goes one I
find to be the most beautiful but it
lets you know that when you're starting
out on this journey with Vimeo that this
is going to be something different they
do this all over the app if you search
for the word fart as you scroll up and
down it makes fart noises as you do this
right there's something different like
this site interactive it's a little bit
magical it's a little bit different and
it's something that you want to talk
about you don't have to always do it
with design this is the signup form for
cork which used to be a social network
for people who loved to drink wine on it
it says email address it's also your
seinem and has to be legit first name or
your mom calls you last name what your
army buddies call you pass or something
you remember but hard to guess password
confirmation think it type it again
think of it as a test it's literally a
poem as you fill out the form right and
this is the kind of like thing where
you're like oh I like the people behind
us I'm going to enjoy this experience
what does it say when you fill out a
form like this right Yahoo about what
the personality of this site is going to
be and what's disappointing to me is
like dot enforces every product and
service under them to use this exact
same login form Flickr I had thought had
one of the best sort of call to actions
it was get in there right this is her
Roku's signup page innocent older
version but what's remarkable about it
is that what you start getting a feel
for is like oh scaling up my sort of
server back-end services is as easy as
it's sort of dragging up and down
different sort of knobs and levers to be
beautiful use and it looks fairly easy
to scale since we're in a room full of
computer science people I think you
appreciate this this chocolate this is a
code editor and they only have one call
to action when the time limited is up
they said everything in terms of all the
pieces are exactly the same except we
change the font to Comic Sans and what
they're basically saying is like hey we
know who our users are who our real
customers are and they're going to be
the people who care about this this is
hurl this is website for checking HTTP
requests and sometimes the places where
you get errors are opportunities for
first moments if you hit up 404 this is
what you get when we need help
oftentimes what we do is we create like
really beautiful mark marketing
materials but when you actually need
like documentation we sort of like skimp
out on sort of design features and this
is a point that like you see happen over
and over again a company that gets us
right is MailChimp and what they did was
they redesign all their help guides so
that they look like magazine covers and
overnight basically readership goes up
on all these features and customer
support for these things that sort of
helps people optimize emails goes down
speaking of documentation stripe what's
interesting about an API company is that
there is no UX the UX is actually just
documentation right and there's
opportunities even in documentation sort
of the enchant amaze so one of the
things that I love about them is their
examples are wonderful but if you're
actually like sort of logged into the
app one of the things that is a super
pain for most people when you're dealing
most people's api's is like grabbing
your API credentials and keys and what
stripe does is it says oh if you're
logged into the app we automatically put
your API credentials into the examples
so you only have to copy paste paste
ones when trying to learn their API when
we food one does it launch the third
version or by API we realize like ok
that finally this is good enough that we
want people to sort of build on top of
it we're trying to figure out like how
do we launch this out to the world that
sort of has our personality behind it
because a lot of people they usually do
things like a programming API content
and I give out iPads and iPhones and it
makes you look like everyone else
and so in our company one weird value of
they have a quirk of us is that the
co-founders are big medieval nuts and we
would take everyone out to medieval
times every single year on the
anniversary of the founding of the
company and so we said we have to do
something in that flavor and so we
contacted the guys at armored comm we
said can you forge us a custom battle
axe and what we said was if you win our
programming contest you would win one
and the result is like people wanted to
talk about this it was something that
people wanted to work on because they
wanted to be able to say like I'm
programming for a weapon and what's cool
is we had over 25 different applications
created for us of quality and quantity
that we could not have paid for on the
budget and it sort of time that we had
for this yeah things like an iPhone app
an Android app and WordPress plugins
right and all because what we did was we
changed how people want to talk about
the origin story of how they're
interacting with one of our services
bingo like all day long going over these
examples but we sure cut just by saying
you should just subscribe to little big
details it's just basically tons of
screenshots of software that's just
doing it right that shows that they're
being conscientious
of the user and the customers when it
comes to long-term relationships or
marriages the only research that we
ended up having to read is the stuff
that was done by John Gottman he's been
featured in this American Life and
Malcolm Gladwell's books
he's a marriage researcher up in Seattle
and he has an interesting parlor trick
that he can do he can watch a videotape
of a couple fighting about some issue
for 15 minutes and predict with an 85%
accuracy rate whether that couple will
be together or not or divorced in four
years if he increases that video up to
an hour and ask them to also talk about
their hopes and dreams that prediction
rating goes up to 94% they showed these
same video tapes to marriage counselors
successfully married couples
sociologists psychiatrists priests etc
and they can't predict with random
chance whether people going to be
together or not
so John Gottman understands something
fundamental about how relationships work
in the long term and that basically how
we fight even in the short term period
could indicate sort of the whole system
and what it's going to look like and one
of the surprising things he discovered
is not that successfully married people
don't fight at all turns out everybody
fights and we all fight about the exact
same things money kids sex time and
others and others are things like
jealousy and the in-laws to bring this
around right you can actually atribute
every single one of these two problems
that you see in customer support when
you're building out your product
[Applause]
right so the cost too much I'm having
problems with credit card if you're
building a service that helps people
deal with their clients they're very
centered about anything happening with
that performance how long you're up and
how fast others are said jealousy and
in-laws right so that competition and
partnership so anything weird happening
there people going to write to you about
and the reason I like to think about
this in terms of customer support is
that everyone started processing like a
conversion funnel posture support is the
thing that happens in between every one
of these steps it's the reason why
people don't make it further down there
it's the thing that prevents conversion
from happening now as we were thinking
through all these ideas and as we're
building up the company we realize that
there's a big problem about how everyone
sort of starts their company are built
up they're sort of engineering teams and
that is there's a broken feedback loop
there people are divorced from the
consequences of their actions and this
is a result of actually the natural
evolution of how both companies get
founded especially by technical
co-founders right before launch it's a
time of bliss Nirvana and opportunity
right nothing that you do is wrong right
by your hand which you feel is like God
everything that you write every line of
code feels perfect right and it's a
genius to you the thing that happens is
after launch reality sort of sets in and
then all these other tasks sort of come
into place that we have to deal with now
what technical co-founders want to do is
get back to that initial state and so
what we often do and what we often see
is that companies start siloing off all
these other things that actually is what
makes a start-up or a company sort of
real right and have other people do them
too in our minds these other tasks are
inferior right and we have other people
in company do them and so for us what
we're trying to figure out is how do we
change software development so that we
inject some values that we don't talk
about enough responsibility
accountability humility modesty right
and we call this um like a lot of other
people we add a acronym support driven
development is basically very similar to
TD
or other agile practice it's a way of
creating high quality software but it's
super simple you don't need like a scrum
you don't need a bunch of post-it notes
all you have to do is make everyone do
customer support and what you end up
having is you fix the feedback loop
right the people who build the software
are the ones supporting it and you get
all these sort of nice benefits as a
result so one of them is support
responsible developers and designers and
people build the stuff they give the
very best support now we're not the
first person to think of this Paul
English was a big purport of this at
kayak and what he did was install a read
customer support phone line in the
middle of the engineering floor and
we're just reading with customer support
calls and people would ask him
oftentimes why would you pay engineers
hundred twenty thousand dollars or more
to do something that you can pay other
people a fraction of the handle in like
a call center and he says well after the
second or third time that that phone
rings and the engineer gets the same
problem they stop what they're doing
they fix the bug you stop getting phone
calls about it it's a way of having QA
in a sort of nice elegant solution now
john gottman talks about the reasons
that we often break up with one another
as due to four major causes and they're
warning signs he calls his own four
horsemen right criticism contempt
defensiveness and stonewalling that
criticism is basically people's starting
to focus not just on the specific issue
at hand but on the overarching issues
like you never write listen to users or
you never think about us all the time
right content is when someone is
purposely trying to insult somebody
defenses this is not trying to take
accountability trying to make excuses
for the actions and stonewalling is
basically shutting down so in lolling to
John Gottman is one of the worst things
that we can do in a relationship hold up
and oftentimes you know we don't worry
much about this and customer sort
criticism and content right defenses
this you see this all the times in
companies especially as they get older
but stonewalling is this something I see
happen which startups all the time you
get a bunch of cuts to the sort sort of
coming in and you just think I don't
need to answer it I don't need to
respond right and that act is just not
even getting back to them it's one of
the worst things you can do it's
probably some of the biggest causes of
churn in the early stages of startups
this is how support worked out woohoo
when we require grant about five hundred
thousand users on the system five
million people use route forms and
reports whether they knew it or not and
all those people got support from the
same ten people and usually there's only
one person dedicated support a day or
any any shift resulted about four
hundred issues a week it's about eight
hundred email but a response time from
9:00 a.m. to 9:00 p.m. was between seven
to twelve minutes right from 9:00 p.m.
to midnight it was an hour and then on
the weekend it would be no longer than
24 hours and we carried this up all the
way up to this scale what a lot of
people forget about and often talk about
with Airbnb as how's like oh they did
this interesting thing where they had
went up to New York and offered like
professional photographers and the
founders would go out there and actually
take pictures of the people's apartments
up and sell more focusing on the stories
around conversion what most people don't
realize is a lot of times when I saw Joe
in the early days of Airbnb get a phone
sort of headset stuck to his head all
the time because who's doing phone
support non-stop turn is a story that we
don't like to talk about ovens all the
time Airbnb sort of growth really
started picking up what they figured out
how to match capacity to the demand or
the phone calls they were getting into
their support system at wound food we
actually constantly did experiments
around support because we're so obsessed
with it one experiment we did was we
heard Kathy Sierra do a talk about
there's a disconnect between the
emotions that we have when we need help
and sort of the content and the
reactions we get from people and when we
get help from them especially online
because they just don't see all those
nonverbal cues so she said unless
there's face recognition on the web
we're just always going to be
disconnected
our users our feeling was like well
we're not recognition experts or what I
think means another way of getting
empathy so as form builders we added a
drop-down and what we said was like okay
what's your emotional state and our
hypothesis was that no one was going to
fill this out we basically thought oh
okay you know what this is going to be
pretty lame experiment but we'll see how
it sort of goes and it turned out the
emotional state drop-down field was
filled out seventy five point eight
percent of the time the browser type
drop-down field just in comparison was
so about seventy eight point one percent
of the time right
so people were basically telling us for
my technical support issue how I feel
about this problem is just as important
as like all the technical details you
need to sort of figure out how to debug
it now we did prioritize things or
triage things by emotion right for the
most part people then gain the system
when an interesting byproducts of it was
that we noticed that people started
being nicer to us and the fresh support
it was something sort of subconscious we
just were thinking like well our users
are so much better now what's going on
and we went back and looked at the data
and did some text analysis and we
realized is that oh when it comes to
only its communicating with people over
written words like email there's only
three ways that you show strong emotions
right exclamation marks curse words and
all paths and sure enough on all three
of those metrics they've gone down in
sort of the way people were talking to
us and the pressure support once people
had a simple outlet for their emotions
right it will be a lot more rational and
it made our job a lot more pleasant as a
result does it by product that is
awesome is that you actually build
better software when you do this far
better software this is actually backed
up by tons of research Jared spool a
user interface engineering which is sort
of the big players and the space says
like there's a direct correlation to how
much time we spend with directly exposed
to users and how good our designs sort
of get he says it has to come in a
specific way actually direct exposure
right it can't be something where
someone generates a report or through a
graph you ask me interacting them
somewhat real-time has to be a minimum
of every six weeks and that's me for at
least two hours otherwise your software
will get worse over time
our developers are people who are on
with you we're getting exposed to our
users four to eight hours every single
week and what it does is it changes the
way you sort of build software Jared
spool has another way of talking about
how we build products right and let's
imagine that this represents all the
knowledge needed to sort of use your app
on a spectrum right this is like no
knowledge right this is all the
knowledge needed right and these two
lines are pretty much your interaction
with users what you're trying to get
them to this is currently where their
knowledge point is and this is the
target knowledge point that you're
trying to get them to to understand and
use your app the gap between those is
called the knowledge gap Jared called
those calls and what's interesting about
this is there's only two ways right to
sort of fix this that gap represents how
intuitive your app is right you either
get a user to increase their knowledge
or you decrease the amount of knowledge
that's needed to use your application
and oftentimes as engineers and people
who build and work on products we think
let's add new feature and new features
only means let's increase the knowledge
gap so for us we actually focus a lot on
the other sort of direction
and so that meant is we spent a lot of
time thirty percent of our engineering
time was spent on internal tools to help
with our customer support stuff but
often times it was spent helping people
help themselves
things like frequently asked questions
tool tips things like if you just click
the help link right instead of taking to
the generic help sort of documentation
page you go to the specific page where
you're looking at that's going to be
most sort of appropriate for what you're
working on we redesigned our
documentation over and over again a be
tested it constantly one iteration of
our documentation reduced customer
support by 30 percent overnight it's one
of those things where like overnight all
the people that work on the product
immediately had 30% less work to do now
what happens if you have everyone work
on customer support
constantly thinking about in terms of a
remarkable way well I talked a lot of
in the very beginning growth is a
function of conversion and churn this is
refused growth curve for the first five
years right what's interesting is we
paid no money on advertising on
marketing all of it was done by word of
mouth growth right and the interaction
between like new users and downgrades
are this it's so slight what it takes
that gap making that sort of work and
what a lot of people keep forgetting is
that there's almost no difference
between an increase in conversion rate
one percent increase and a one percent
decrease in churn they do exactly the
same thing to your growth however the
latter is actually much easier to do
it's much cheaper to do in your app and
a lot of times we neglect this neglect
this - way far along right and we
usually have our B team works on these
sort of projects and services this is
actually not the graph that we track
most a time it's not even the one I'm
proud of this is the one I'm proud of
because even though we had this sort of
nice awesome curve of growth this is
what allowed us to scale keep the
company small have an awesome culture
and that required doing a lot of these
things to help people sort of do what
they need so John Gottman noticed there
was a different type of behavior for
relationships and why people divorce
basically there would be some subset of
people who would stay together 10 15
years and then all of a sudden they
divorce and there was none of that other
indicators which sort of show that this
is what was going to happen and I was
looking through the data and they
realized oh there's no passion there's a
fire between these people right when it
comes to relationships they kind of
follow the second law of thermodynamics
right in a closed energy system things
tend to run down so you have to
constantly be putting energy and effort
back into it now the way a lot of people
sort of think about showing people that
I care about you in products and in
companies is to do things like a blog
right let's have a newsletter the thing
is we'd look at these rates and
basically it's such a small percentage
of our active users that it was like
most of our users have no idea all the
awesome stuff that we're
for them so we built a new tool we call
it the roof rule alert system and what
allowed us to do is just timestamp every
new feature that we're building for
users and then every time they would log
in we would look at the difference
between their login time or last login
time and the new features that were
implemented and we had this message show
up hey since you've been gone here's all
the awesome stuff that we did for you
hands down this is the most talked about
feature I've ever had every time I went
out to talk to users right they'd say
like dude I love that since you good
since you've been gone saying even
though I pay the same amount every
single month you guys are doing
something for me almost every week it's
totally awesome
makes me have someone get I'm getting
maximum value of the thing that we did
in addition to having everyone support
the people that paid that paycheck
that's in safe thank you and this was a
large part due to us injecting sort of
humility and modesty into sort of the
equation every single Friday we would
get together and we just write simple
handwritten thank-you cards to our users
and I know there's tons of people who
would not be sort of excited about doing
this but it was a ritual that made sort
of all the difference in terms of like
having a team that was very tightly neat
tightly knit also and working on stuff
that they really cared about they're
always constantly what the mission was
for and why we sort of did what we did
these aren't fancy thank-you cards right
they're just simple like handwritten
stuff on an index card we threw in a
sticker and slapped on the dinosaur on
the front of it and what's interesting
is we started this practice as a result
of the early days of starting gufu Chris
Ron and I were talking and we're trying
to figure out what are we going to do
some sort of shore users that we
appreciate them around Christmas and he
Chris came up with this idea where he
said hey guys so a couple years ago my
mom like made me write thank-you notes
to all my relatives for my Christmas
gifts and I didn't really like to do it
but following year all my presents were
super good so I think we should try this
for our business and see how come
so that first year we wrote handwritten
Christmas cards to all of our users that
first year second year rolls around and
we have too many customers like and it's
still just a three founder and we're
going like we're kind of screwed I don't
know what we're going to do and we read
a book called the awesome question and
in it he talks about hey just focus on
your most profitable users - just send
them and take care of them thing will
work out so like all right that makes
sense that's scalable so that your we
only write to our highest paying
customers and the January rolls around
that second year and one of our longtime
loyal users write to us and he's
basically like hey guys I I really loved
that Christmas card you sent me the
first year and I just wanted you to know
I haven't received my second card yet
and I'm just looking forward to I know
you didn't forget about me thanks a lot
so we're like [ __ ] because best way to
sort of exceed expectations and not
spending to begin with so we were like
sort of in this conundrum and what we
decided after think about it for a while
is that we need to stop doing it you
know just one time a year
it needs to be something that's part of
the culture happens every every every
sort of week even and even though we'll
never catch up to all of our customers
just the practice of doing it will make
all the difference I talk a lot about a
bunch of like lovey-dovey stuff and sort
of like touchy-feely things that I think
a lot of engineers don't like to think
about too often so I'll end on some sort
of hard business data or research
there's an article that put out by the
Harvard Business Review several years
ago by Michael Tree seeing Fred woods
Erma and in it they talked about the
discipline of market leaders they say
there's only three ways that you achieve
market dominance and depending on how
you want to achieve that market
dominance you have to organize your
company in a very specific way best
price best product the best overall
solution
want to be the best price out there you
focus on logistics so Walmart and Amazon
if you want to be the best product out
that your focus on R&D Apple's usually a
quintessential example of that best
overall solution
it's about being customer intimate and
this is the path that you see followed
by luxury brands and hospitality and
stray what I love about this path
towards market dominance is that the
third one is only one that everyone can
do at any stage of their company parts
almost no money to get started with
usually just requires a little bit of
humility and some manners and as a
result you can achieve the success as
any other people instead of your market
that's all I got
thank you very much yeah let's take some
questions yes Emily we're in the back
there possible different types of users
how deep is one for us all the flow
maybe the speakers at one good night
could attract fun come on it so what do
you do when you have a product with lots
of different type of users right some
users will have one thing in another
world well another and I agree there's a
interesting fine line for that what I
always usually tell people it's focus on
the people who are the most passionate
especially in the early stages right
whoever's whatever niche it's going to
be that's who I focus on completely
things that a lot of different products
did I think Ben's element of Pinterest
started off with design bloggers right
curtail your thing for them and
eventually you'll figure out sort of
universal values that will appeal to a
lot of other people so just start one at
a time and a lot of examples that you
see up there a lot of people make the
mistake is like oh I'll just make my app
funny
what humor is like really difficult to
do right when you want to shoot for
something sort of witty and quite
honestly you have to get functionality
right so like the Japanese quality if
you don't have at item a on there right
don't try to do anything witty
right there's it'll backfire on you so
hands down our number one focus would
make it as easy to use as possible for
with you and anything else on top was
polish right here oh you so anybody
played that in focus
I'm also very light I love a good
pro-life and I'm not related to bad but
we are at a certain point that we are
focusing on for that but we don't get
like top concern right now some second
thing so how much we should focus on
product but because we should do now
marketing you should not get some other
customers only and I start talking to
customers but when were to focus on your
product like desire right so what
exactly you gave me when you are saying
that focus for you and your products and
give it better so ok so the question
sort of is how do we balance this sort
of thing where we want to be obsessed
with working on product yet with all the
other skills and sort of pass under
needed by company like marketing
branding and all that stuff but not
probably sort of balance that and the
thing is like which stars you're
juggling like tons of things constantly
in the air the thing is if you're
working on products like you should also
always have this flip side is when
you're talking to users right and for us
inside it flew through the way we got
people to talk to users is they just did
customer support and I got to see
firsthand right away whether the feature
sucked or not and it also impacted
everyone else in the company because
everyone had a customer support ship so
you have this sort of social incentive
to sort of make everything work and so
like I said there should be no point
where you only focus on product you
should always have time where you work
on products and then you see sort of
what users say to you and you should
always have this virtual like feedback
loop on there so be careful when you
don't have that usually what ends up
happening if you're lucky in terms of
marketing in sales like usually my
feeling is like you having to spend
money on marketing and advertising all
that stuff it's usually attacks you pay
because you haven't made your product
remarkable right word-of-mouth growth is
the easiest kind of growth and it's a
lot of the great companies sort of grow
so figure out how to wait
how to like have a story that people
want to tell about your product where
they're the most interesting person at
the dinner table right and then that
person is your sales person right that
person is your sales force for you right
here
our user need and the demand area is the
right solution how do you communicate
with engineering to make sure that you
have time for the champion and for every
other day I can make a decision that's
weird
Oh so how do you make a decision on
product and communicate that with your
sort of engineering team when there's
like lots of different directions to go
my feeling is that so for us we just
looked at supporting it was really easy
because you often just saw what are the
things that people having the most
amount of problems with or people asking
all the time you cannot help but get
feature requests from people no matter
like whatever opening or orifice you
have in your product or app people will
like jam feature requests in there so
you're easily going to know sort of what
they sort of want your job as a product
person an engineer it's to not just do
what they say because that way you'll
just be a slave is to figure out sort of
deeply what are the reasons why
underlying those things and sort of
solve that deep underlying reason the
thing is that everyone has once I have a
different way to to sort of go then
ultimately it comes down to like
someone's going to figure something out
but also make the smallest version of
each little idea no longer than a week
or two weeks to build it out there and
you can try them out and see sort of
what works it don't work I think it's
dangerous that have multiple different
product directions that requires lots of
time to sort of stick around Sam how's
the cake ready yeah ok so so I don't
like hackathons I think they sort of
suck in terms of one's own inside of
companies because you spend like 48
hours like working on something really
hard that you're sort of passionate
about and 99% of them never make it to
production right and it's sort of sort
of really super sad so for us he's like
flipping on Titan we came with an idea
that we called keen for a day and it
actually worked over the weekend but how
it worked is someone randomly in the
company got drawn and they got to be the
king and the King got to tell everyone
else what to do on the product so
everything that was bothering them about
wifu it was a customer support store
some features they really want to have
they got engineering resources the
marketing reach of the advertising
resources of everyone inside of the
company to make it sort of happen and of
course we worked with them to figure out
like what can be actually done in 48
hours but we would do this one to two
times a year and I was like a huge hit
and it was a boost to morale because
what people most loved is like working
on things where it's like oh I made a
difference so yeah right
and so for us that's one way that we
would like sort of divide time for like
product direction it's like sometimes
the people that work for you they have a
strong opinion about where it where it
should go and that's a good way to sort
of democratize it a little bit by
rotating it around yes
yeah hello usually they're here yeah
okay so we all work from home so I will
tell you that we all still work with in
the Tampa Bay area we would allow
anybody work from anywhere but usually
as we try to recruit them they sort of
meet our team and they just decide okay
we just want to come and move here
anyway remote working is especially
tricky it's a lot of people like to
romanticize it especially people who are
like employees but the thing is an
office gives you a lot of sort of
benefits right and efficiencies that you
now have to compensate for when you have
remote working but remember we can also
have these other sort of efficiencies in
place for example I don't have to worry
about my employees losing two hours of
their day to commuting for instance so
the biggest thing that we had to do for
working is a respect people's time and
so the way we had it set up is we
actually had a four and a half day work
week at blue so half day on Friday was
for all the meetings and stuff we said
like no business do meetings no talking
with other outside parties they'd also
be done on Friday on that half day it
couldn't be done in the middle of the
week and then also one day of everyone
was already dedicated customer support
so everyone in our company effectively
only had three days each week to
actually build or work on whatever they
were doing but I actually firmly believe
that if you have three solid days right
eight to ten hours where you're only
working on what you need to build you
can get a ton of [ __ ] done and so what
we said was get the research everyone's
time during that three-day period if
they're in that three-day period and
what we came up with a 15 minute rule
and the way it worked is on
you can have a discussion like a chat or
a phone call or whatever with someone
but it could go no longer than 15
minutes so if you have some complicated
issue that you couldn't figure out we'd
say at 15 minutes you are to immediately
table that item right and have us
discuss it on Friday and you need to
move on to the next item on your list
right the hands productivity more often
than not I would say 90% of the time the
item never got brought up on Fridays
because usually what happens people
would sleep on it and then they just
magically say like hey I found a
solution or like hey that's not a big
problem whatsoever because most problems
inside of company don't need to be
solved in real time or right away
the only things are when like the site
is down or payments aren't working right
everything outside of that is basically
kind of luxury so focus on your
priorities as much as possible and as a
result our 10-person team did far more
there's many many other companies as a
result but it takes extra work to make
remote working happen we are an
extremely disciplined sort of team and I
would have to say there's almost not
many YC companies that actually have
been able to replicate sort of what we
do I think there's only two other
companies I think in white seed that
sort of have the same sort of discipline
working style it takes more work in a
very different fashion right an office
allows you to be a little bit lazier
right in terms of all these things
around productivity okay over here oh
just to go over a question has the
leader seen how did you manage to
instill common culture but and also the
house accountability of the employee
expression because anything what we see
okay how do we how do we set up
accountability for employees as a
manager all right so we've who we were
profitable nine months after launch so
we had profit sharing right and so it
makes it senses pretty simple and clear
it would be a multiple of whatever bonus
pool that we sort of had and the
performance measures would be based on
sort of how they did in customer support
right on their duties there and sort of
what they said they were wanting to
accomplish or do I don't like process
and I don't like lots of tools to help
get people to be productive so
only thing that we had for helping
people manage to large part of their
projects is to-do list and that is like
simple text files that we shared in a
Dropbox account each person had their
name on it and you got to see every time
someone updated their to-do list when we
said it every single night just said
everything you did that day right and
then on Friday we just go over okay this
is what you said last week that you're
going to do this is what you actually
got done or does sort of the problems at
hand and it's super simple right it
creates this like nice written trail for
how to sort of handle stuff right and I
don't have to worry about managing them
right they sort of set the tone for how
they want to be sort of assessed and it
makes it really simple and for people
who are excellent at what they do right
it works very very well and then we
actually have problems it's very easy to
fire people I was fortunate that I never
had to fire anyone at we foo right but
we were able to correct a lot of
people's behavior very very quickly
because we just kind of look at this
it's like look this is your pattern of
behavior you finish a fraction of the
items on your list you do most of the
items at the last second right before
Friday
that's a problem you've got to manage
your time better and this is evidence
that you've provided to us all we have
to do is sort of describe it back to you
and because everyone in the company sort
of sees it right there's social pressure
that's put in the place that helps make
it all sort of happen right here you
hire people that yourself with people
who work in this kind of environment
standard so I hire people that can work
remotely and then sort of work in the
certain fashion so pretty easily you
have them work on a side project for you
so you contract them out and don't have
to work remotely as such usually the
project I like to have them work on is
about a month long all right I could do
things much faster for a week but
usually get a good sense of like how
well people sort of manage themselves
and work on things from a project like
that so that was always the first
assessment like we never did anything
just by interviews the other thing had
to sort of screen them for is I really
do do customer support because not and
every engineer sort of has empathy
skills to handle that stress so
sometimes I would have people write
breakup letters to me right in an
interview and just like hey pretend like
you have to break up with me you have 15
minutes to write writing down there you
can only fry it by hand what do
going to say and so you get a good sense
of sort of their writing skills because
like 90% of what you do in customer
support is tell them bad news like we
don't support that feature sorry that's
not going to work or it's not going to
be available and so people have to have
sort of tact at that one question right
here glasses
Eloise like Jamie's parents they're
really often company wasn't anywhere at
have all these tricks and experiments to
help the company are there any ones that
didn't work out alright I'll talk about
one so one of the things that we did
early on to try to motivate ourselves
was try to get like we understood this
idea of like crunch mode and then it's
really bad for people like if you're
doing a subscription business you need
people to last for the long term and
video games a lot of times they're like
crunch people all the time for like a
specific deadline or have multiple
sprints every two weeks and you have to
shoot up to this deadline and it's like
exhausting and so people because what
does happening is like you might get an
increase in productivity but the
recovery period that you need for people
is always greater right then the
productivity you gain and a company
where you need everyone doing customer
support and being on their game and
constant push not features you don't
have time for recovery so we were
thinking about okay we want to build
like a company vacation into how we fee
sort of works to reward our users every
single year and we said okay if the
occasion is sort of built in that for
the recovery we could have one crunch
period right before that vacation set up
and we'll just only do customer support
that will sort of scale with people so
the way we did the very first crunch
mode is that it was just between the
three founders and we had each of us
draw up a tenth item to-do list that
would be fairly aggressive and the first
person to get through seven of their
items would win and the last person to
get through seven other items would
become what we called trip [ __ ] and
trip [ __ ] meant that you carried the
other person's luggage and got people
drinks when you're on the company
vacation so we did that and during that
period everyone was like pretty excited
about it and motivated and when the
winner got to choose the next company
vacation the following year and then all
of a sudden Ryan I basically poorly
estimated the items
on his list and he realized very quickly
I'm going to [ __ ] lose and so he was
just like I give up and he just sort of
stops Oh crunch mode turned out to be
blob mode for him because he knew he was
going to lose it game pretty demoralized
so as a result of doing that we decided
not to do it in that similar fashion
anymore so good idea that we like to
talk about but it's one that we never
did again alright guys thanks a lot you
can email me at Kevin at Y Combinator
calm
[Applause]